617 830 4750 is the number please start
by telling us your name and where you're
calling from um hi my name is Allison
Jackie I'm calling from Rutgers
University all right what's on your mind
today okay so today there's like this I
think its national there's a national
walk out of class day in order to
protest Donald Trump and I met a bit of
a crossroads here um on one hand I am
someone who's been very critical of many
of these protest movements and I don't
like going with the crowd so much at the
same time I am very against Donald Trump
right um i'm not in favor of people the
people who are saying unless there's
like some indication that there actually
is rigging i'm not in favor of like
these people who are just trying to
change the election after fact the same
time i think the worst uh presidential
any president-elect ever um so I am very
morally confused about whether I want to
join in this protest with people but
they don't agree with on a lot of things
but I so love meaning but yeah I'm very
conflicted listen I've been talking to
people about this number one we found
out like at one protest in Oregon half
of the people protesting didn't vote now
it's Oregon which was very easily blue
and so specifically half of those people
voting would not have changed the
election results not voting whatever did
didn't make an impact and I'm don't
subscribe to this idea that if you don't
vote you can't complain you can complain
no matter what that that's absolutely
something that is completely American
and part of what it is that this country
is it and means i agree with you i
stopped by some Trump protests in
massachusetts over the weekend and I was
sort of disappointed in the sense that
it was if people are just getting their
emotions out right now that's absolutely
fine and I respect that but really what
progressive need is organization for the
next two four and six years and there's
a lot going on that we need organization
around and I saw no indication from the
protest I went to that the progressives
that at least were protesting we're
ready for that and that's the concern
yet going or not to the poorest and i do
what do what you wanted for example
they're calling it a sanctuary movement
like sanctuary on and to me that on
college campuses like we need the
sanctuary and to me that just sounds so
much like safe space but it was a
spaceman college from history and want
to be if we're actually trying to oppose
someone who's going to the authoritarian
and say we're not here with this on
history that to me is something
important but I'm very confused about
where I'm standing right now yeah no I
agree with you on that we'll listen if
you go to the protest call back in next
week and let us know sort of what you
saw there I I would like to be inspired
by what I'm seeing but I'm seeing a lot
of lack of organization and sort of
concern about will these protests lead
to anything tangible and that that's
really what I want to see ya Allison
thanks so much great to hear from you
okay thank you very much